[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log stardate 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who were you talking uh no one you were
narrating again i was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to that i know that narrating
helps me focus
ready captain light you ready as i'll
ever be commander hawthorne this is
exciting a new adventure i'm gonna grant
you four minutes to be off planet but
then you come right back to us
to infinity and beyond
and you are clear for hyper launch
buzz that was utterly terrifying and i
regret having joined you
i'd like you to star command come in
star command
why don't they answer
the robots the what
what is happening right now
alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
sucks how long have we gone yum yum yum
yum yum 62 years seven months and five
days
what
i hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
i have a plan and i have a team darby
can take any three things and make them
explode
i do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well i thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not
did i get it pretty close i need that
you don't see the harpoons
[Music]
right here
[Music]
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 hmm seems a
bit low mission failure imminent in
three grandma always said she believed
in you too
there was a big swelling too i think i
need a better don't always record your
last words do not vomit inside the
vehicle do not vomit inside the vehicle
if you are satisfied with this recording
speak or select one
[Music]
to infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that
sorry it's the thing your grandma and i
used to do yeah
good night good night
yes yes yes good night
[Music]
there are a lot of other villains in the
world
but i am going to be
a super villain
[Music]
i am pretty despicable
all right all right i'm not minnie
please stop calling me that
time to strike
[Music]
my minions will save me
you like picking on little guys huh
i am a master of kung fu
uh
for smoochy smoochy
i will teach you
here
kevin kevin kevin
um
[Music]
[Music]
why don't we make this a fair fight
okay
i'm
all right tv night with my pro
you're going on a date with lois so
disrespectful
oh hey there little fella
wake up buddy it is one o'clock i
[Music]
with other animals this just seems gross
we need gross smelling stuff is one of
the greatest joys of being a dog next to
licking any part of your body and i lick
myself all the time well that explains
the breath
superman i am lulu and you will kneel
before me
oh aren't you a little ray of sunshine
what's going on
[Music]
you're invulnerable i should be a lot
more dead right now right all of us have
superpowers
still working out the kinks i didn't see
anything
are you okay my best friend is in danger
and you have to help me you know what
they say about dogs don't you never feed
us chocolate we love unconditionally
we're just a bunch of shelter pets
[Music]
we'll help you get your dumbo in the
back
hey deploy k-9 here what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
why can't i have gotten a magic hammer
or something
what do i have here
oh squishy bros
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
[Music]
i am known by many names
[Music]
the legend whisperer
i am pursuing boots
holy free college
you launch me
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
hey guys
hey you want to see something cool
get home safely good night
you're still here okay okay one more
number i call this one the legend will
never die
[Music]
i have bad news
you died
doctor
relax i am [ __ ] booze i have night life
and how many times have you died already
uh
i am not really a mad guy
honestly
do you like you does this have shellfish
in it
a cat always lands on his feet what
[Music]
what's happening watch
and then there was the giant today so
what is that like uh
a four
that makes eight puss what do you wish
to do with your last life when you only
have one life
that's what makes it special
fear me if you dare
goldilocks and the three bears crying
family
you're supposed to be dead
it never fails whenever i team up with
you things go wrong trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you killed that cute no
and with the paws it's all so
cute
am i doing it stop you're gonna give
yourself a harness
hello there now i know what you're
thinking crikey a black cat he's gonna
bring me bad luck
shows what you know about luck
let's drop some knowledge
luck is different all around the world
like in scotland where a black cat like
me is considered very lucky remember
kids don't try this at home
name's bob by the way and this is the
land of luck
morning jerry
we work behind the scenes to create
those wee lucky and unlucky moments that
make up your everyday life
like these guys an entire team thinking
up the jammy lack that kind that makes
you feel like a million bucks
okay maybe a hundred bucks of course
then there's the other team
working on the not so jammy kind of luck
and they sure love what they do
well you humans are a complicated lot
and that's why things run so smoothly
here because no human has ever stepped
foot in this place and with a little bit
of luck they never will
uh where am i
oh you gotta be kidding
[Music]
no no no oh
[Music]
god
oh
[Music]
boy oh dad i don't want to stop your
flow but can you pass the pilaf oh
god that's butter you know what butter's
better
you have seven days to make your payment
seven it's gonna be okay bob
happy
hopeful
kissy lips
please
oh my god louise don't go down there
it's dangerous
did you mean to wave your arms all over
the place while falling into the hole
because if so you nailed it yes it all
would great
sister please
i'd like to report
a thing happened
what do we do ideas go oh oh what's this
thing
i'm so nervous
i know can you believe it
[Music]
that feels nice i know i know don't rub
my sesame seeds off i won't don't worry
they're a cute couple uh i give them a
year
what's the first thing that pops into
your head when i say chip and dale i bet
it's these guys but certainly the second
would be those rascally cartoon
chipmunks chip and dale
what if i did something like i am into
good good i love
[Music]
just it to remind you guys i'll be at
fancon this afternoon hey watch out
i'm keeping myself fit and you know my
updated modern look don't you think
you'd have more fans here if chip did
these events with you i haven't thought
about them in a while i should give him
a call see how life's treating him life
is the worst
which is why you need good insurance
a message on my landline
i don't like that
i know you're still mad about rescue
rangers getting canceled but i just got
a call from the police and i need your
help
i searched the perimeter no clues why
would there be six missing tunes in a
month and not one clue
oh no
dale you look
different it's no secret i had the cgi
surgery what's been up with you you know
this that other vague things to fill the
space of this conversation cool
we can see what we can find out and then
pass it along to the officer that that's
all we're gonna do so you're saying the
rescue rangers are back yes
you two come poking around where you
don't belong and i can't have that run i
gotta go
what are you looking at honestly your
weird dead eyes
over here go get em
[Music]
i was always more of an alvin and the
chipmunks person you
monster
[Music]
this is incredible
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me vlogs
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms jackpot yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it all right we're out of here so
long suckers
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic wolf you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would
smack it stab it sauteed
i want you to save it
the good guy we're more than just scary
villains they love us you're such a good
boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra sweet
nope
sucka
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new normal
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
[Music]
you got a minute oh what
when how does she
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
i wear what i want say what i want 24 7
365.
[Music]
am i right
this is gonna be the best year ever
nothing's gonna get in my way
breakfast is ready
[Music]
it's gonna be may
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
oh look at me stay back this happened
already
what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our family
[Music]
you're so cute sick i've always wanted a
tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're
our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion
will release the panda abby hit me
oh
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get ripped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
oh
my whole life i've been perfect little
meimei
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be me
this is the day passport to embarks on
his journey around the world in 80 days
no less thank you everyone thank you
my sweet little baby boy going around
the world i don't think so
mom
i need to explore any cars i am tired of
living in the shadow you know what specs
i'm tired of living in a shadow too how
about tomorrow morning i break you out
of this crib and we get on that early
ferry together around the world
[Music]
bring my baby home
hello come on
[Music]
send
[Applause]
what brings you two into this jungle we
had this idea of beating juan frog de
leon's record by walking how old school
well how would you do it by flying frogs
can't fly frogs who build planes can
frog's book
[Music]
now let's get the ferry there and finish
your trip
wow
[Music]
it's so incredible
[Music]
engine stopped working no need to panic
we're doomed
there we go
hmm quicksand how far can your tongue
reach
[Music]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i literally never
seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
this is it abe moment of truth
remember be keys to success don't screw
up
come on
i can't watch
but i can't look away
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing
that ever happened to me
i can't believe we got to be seen with
that freak chicken here everybody laughs
at me dad would you expect he's mostly
chicken no he's mostly hair shaking
sounds like they're cheering for you
chicken hair chicken hair chicken
if i can bring back the hamster of
darkness
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly trials
why can't it ever be two trials
[Music]
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh please
you couldn't have brought the extra
large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't fly you
can run
i can't fly
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the world
awesome
oh no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ]
crying out now
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like you
i'm starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get
back wild [ __ ] you like a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
i bet i wouldn't stop you from using it
ah
i love family reunions
in a secret place deep inside the forest
the golden egg has chosen i'm a master
rabbit candidate the city rabbit they
make sure every kid gets all of their
easter eggs young rabbits get some
special training if you want to become a
master rabbit you have to take
responsibility you're a rabbit yourself
i know how to get the eggs that's mount
chicken tomorrow we'll steal all the
eggs from up there and on easter sunday
we'll smash them do you trust me with
all our hearts
[Music]
perhaps now fox will have to join forces
with a rabbit to save easter
[Music]
together
oh i wanna together you all over
you're invited to a royally loony movie
event
bark is someone here a long lost member
of the royal family hey that's me
meet the new royal family king tweety
first of his name
now this is for life this pillar this
birdbath this plush carpet is for me
being king is the greatest
with new royal subjects
i'm used to getting attention but this
is where with something else hey dude
stop for a place called the canary
island there sure are a lot of dogs here
get him
that's my brother
and old royal problems
we'll just have to make sure this new
king has an accident as well
i can't let diego in his school sir
tweety
[Music]
[Music]
huh
don't miss the all-new king tweety movie
event
look for it on digital and dvd
when every villain in the dc multiverse
unites to form the legion of doom
one team of heroes
you guys are in trouble now is not going
to be enough for one movie you know you
might want to bring the big guns with
you on this mission
what if i told you i hold the power to
get rid of every superhero
they'll need all the help they can get
they should do things
differently here the entire multiverse
is at stake but if i lose control what
if i hurt someone you might be surprised
what darkness can do if you give it a
chance
i know harleen diana she's not evil but
once this girl's not with anybody
[Music]
i never thought i'd say this but
burritos for lunch was adorable
it's gonna be mayhem great scott what is
this we eat crises have catastrophic
proportions for breakfast that's what
happens to any superhero dumb enough to
face the legion of doom time to kick
some legion butt
teen titans go and dc superhero girls
mayhem in the multiverse look for it on
digital blu-ray and dvd
the giant serpent defeated
the princess was free at last tears
sparkled in her eyes like
the cloak there is no place for a
fragile girl like you sweetie my throat
to be continued
barbara never lived by the rules
until tradition caught up with her
princess barbara
i'm glad to welcome you all honor of my
daughter barbara's
wedding what
fireball what fireball it's a pony
that's a pony
i can't marry that horrid man
now she's getting a crash course
on what it's like out in the wild
who are you i swear i didn't touch
anything
you're princess barbara yes today is
your lucky day cool man we're going to
sell you back to the palace what to the
palace
a royal kid
ugh not to my dad's palace
she's been kidnapped we have to act fast
here you are runner
whoa i
[Music]
you're the kindest monster in the world
all this is mine
life is an adventure
to be traveled together
featuring the voices of paulie shore
haley duff and john heater i ran away to
the ends of the earth to look for my
prince
did you
[Music]
i found him
my sweet monster
[Music]
what
[Music]
bye